Чи справді "Північний потік-2" збільшить енергетичну залежність ЄС від Росії,
чи замерзне без цієї труби Німеччина,
і чи можливо ще зупинити будівництво газопроводу?
DW розвіює найпоширеніші міфи про "Північний потік-2".
Євросоюз фактично дав зелене світло  "Північному потоку-2".
Однак зупинити будівництво все ще може Дональд Трамп.
Президент США неодноразово погрожував запровадити санкції проти західних компаній,
які беруть участь у цьому проекті.
Це, приміром, Allseas Group та Saipem,
яким належать необхідні для реалізації будівництва кораблі-трубоукладачі.
У разі штрафних заходів проти них роботи в морі просто припиняться.
Газом у Німеччині опалюється приблизно половина житлових будинків.
З них російське "блакитне паливо" використовують менше половини.
Тобто від поставок "Газпрому" залежать менше чверті німецьких квартир і будинків.
Крім того, у ФРН багато інших каналів для імпорту газу
та достатньо коштів на оплату екстрених закупівель.
Це поширена думка, адже новий газогін будується для того,
аби здійснювати поставки сибірського газу з Росії
дном Балтійського моря безпосередньо до Німеччини.
Проте це не означає, що увесь газ призначений для Німеччини.
Про це свідчать розміри, маршрут і заброньовані потужності газопроводу EUGAL.
Це сухопутне продовження "Північного потоку-2",
будівництво якого нині також ведеться, і про нього знають далеко не всі.
Кінцева точка газогону розташована біля німецького Грайфсвальда,
де дві його нитки підключать до двох ниток газопроводу EUGAL.
А вони проляжуть східною Німеччиною з півночі на південь і закінчаться в Чехії.
Тож, планується, що близько 90% "блакитного палива" підуть територією Німеччини транзитом.
А його головні отримувачі - Італія,Австрія та інші країни Центральної і Східної Європи.
Нині постачання до цих країн здійснюється через Україну.
Це - ледь не головний аргумент противників "Північного потоку-2".
Проте це не так.
Москва одночасно реалізує одразу два великомасштабні проекти в Європі -
"Північний потік-2" і "Турецький потік" -
для того, щоб звести нанівець або хоча би мінімізувати газовий транзит через Україну.
Обидва газогони мали збудувати до кінця 2019 року.
Цього ж року спливає термін дії угоди про транзит російського газу територією України.
Тож, ідеться про перерозподіл обсягів українського транзиту на нові обхідні маршрути,
а не про збільшення російських поставок у Європу.
Головні загрози для Києва у цьому випадку -
занепад української газотранспортної системи та енергетична ізоляція країни.
Щоправда, і в Берліні, і в Брюсселі наполягають на збереженні транзиту газу через Україну
і після будівництва "Північного потоку-2".
До цього часу в кращому випадку завершиться прокладання двох ниток дном Балтійського моря,
тобто підводна частина проекту,
а під Грайфсвальдом спорудять термінал для прийому газу.
Водночас сухопутний EUGAL до цього часу буде прокладений лише наполовину.
Тож, на повну потужність "Північний потік-2" плюс EUGAL навіть за найсприятливіших обставин
запрацюють не раніше весни 2021 року.
Це означає, що принаймні до того часу "Газпрому" доведеться, як і раніше,
прокачувати значну частину свого європейського газового експорту через Україну.
Тобто Москві та Києву до кінця цього року
треба буде домовитися про подальший транзит газу українською територією.